Hi it's me Michelle from Lab Muffin
Beauty Science possibly the nerdiest
beauty blogger / eatbeast on the Internet.
Today I'm going to be sharing my routine
for getting rid of post acne marks or
post inflammatory hyperpigmentation or
PIH. If you have dark skin or if you have
Asian or African genes you probably have
to deal with post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation. This is when your skin
decides to go into pigment production
overdrive after you have inflammation
like wounds, pimples or sunburn. This
leaves dark marks on your skin that can
be light brown or purpley black. PIH is
really annoying because it's like after
the pimple leaves
its annoying shadow lingers and lingers
and lingers for weeks and weeks and
weeks. Different things work for
different people but here's what I found
works really well for my post
inflammatory hyperpigmentation. It might
work for you as well, let me know if it
does.
A good sunscreen makes a huge difference
for fading my pigment. In particular I
found that switching to a sunscreen that
has high UVA protection helps a lot. I
would say that sunscreen is probably the
number one thing that's faded my pigment.
UVA is longer wavelengths of UV that
tend to cause more photoaging, so
wrinkles, pigmentation - than burning,
which is mostly caused by shorter
wavelengths in the UVB region. Most
sunscreens are really good at blocking
UVB, which is mostly measured by SPF, so
SPF is 80 to 90% caused by UVB. The
dangers of UVB have been known for ages
but UVA is a relatively new development
so not all sunscreens are good at
blocking UVA yet, because of the
regulations which haven't changed that
much for many years. And in particular a
lot of sunscreens aren't that good at
blocking the longest wavelengths of UVA
which is known as UVA1. Annoyingly
longer UVA wavelengths do still cause
pigmentation. There aren't that many
ingredients that are good at blocking
longer wavelengths of UVA. In the US
there's really only avobenzone and
zinc oxide, which in my opinion both kind
of suck. Avobenzones really good at
blocking UVA but it's not photostable
which means that after you've exposed it
to too much UV light - after it's absorbed
too much and turnéd that into heat - it's
going to start breaking down, and once
it's broken down it's not going to
absorb UV anymore, so your skin's no
longer protected. The amount for avobenzone
is really quite low, so if it's by
itself in a sunscreen it turns out that
it's mostly broken down after about an
hour or two. There are ingredients that
can help stabilise avobenzone in
sunscreens but still it's not ideal so
this is part of the reason why they tell
you to reapply your sunscreen. Zinc oxide
on the other hand is photostable but it
doesn't block UVA very well and in
general you can't really get a PPD or
UVA protection factor of more than
around 20. It's also more prone to issues
like clumping on your skin after it's
been there for too long and if it's
clumped up that means it's not
spread out evenly and so sunlight can
get in between those zinc oxide clumps.
In other countries like Europe (I know it's not a country) and Japan
and Australia where I am there are more
options for sunscreens that can block
UVA1. There are actually sunscreens
that can get PPD values of over 40 so
this is similar to SPF except for
something called persistent pigment
darkening which happens with UVA. The
sunscreen ingredients that can help
sunscreens get to these really really
high UVA protection factors are newer
photostable organic sunscreens - in other
words they are so-called chemical
sunscreens. Some of these are Tinosorb S
and Tinosorb M, Mexoryl SX which is
allowed in the US, Mexoryl XL,
and Uvinul A Plus. Unfortunately these
haven't been approved in the US yet but
you can easily get these sunscreens
online. My favorite ingredients have been
Tinosorb S and M, and Tinosorb S is
actually in my favorite sunscreen for
daily use which is  Ultraceuticals
Ultra UV Daily Moisturiser SPF 30. Even
though it's only SPF 30 the texture is
really really nice and it spreads and
dries really easily so I can apply a lot
of this sunscreen. And since sunscreen
protection scales with how much you
apply I probably end up getting more
protection with this SPF 30 sunscreen
than I would with a thicker greasy SPF
50 sunscreen. Most sunscreens also clog
my pores which gives me more acne and
therefore more hyperpigmentation, but
this one doesn't. It also works really
really well under my makeup, it doesn't
boil up or anything like that.
I don't know what I'd do for PIH if I
didn't have vitamin C. It does a bunch of
things for pigmentation. The first step
in producing melanin pigment in your
body is turning the amino acid tyrosine
into l-dopa which is then turned into
dopaquinone. The dopaquinone
eventually turns into melanin. The enzyme
tyrosinase does both of these steps - it's
like a tiny factory. Vitamin c undoes the
second reaction so it slows down pigment
production. Vitamin C is also a really
really good antioxidant when UVA
interacts with skin it forms reactive
substances with unpaired electrons
called free radicals. These free radicals
are super reactive and they're so
reactive that they'll start reacting
willy-nilly with things in your skin - so
things like DNA, proteins and lipids. And
in this process it damages them and this
process, which is sometimes called
oxidative stress, leads to pigmentation.
Vitamin C reacts with free radicals and
stabilizes them so they can't react with
and damage other substances. This means
that you get less new pigmentation which
means that your skin is able to heal
existing pigmentation, and this happens
with the sunscreen as well. I'm quite
basic with my vitamin C so my favorite
vitamin C product is just a DIY vitamin
C serum that I make fresh with ascorbic
acid powder, water and baking soda, and I
have to remake it every week because
firstly the vitamin C isn't stabilized
so starts breaking down quite quickly,
and it's also doesn't have a
preservative. And while it's acidic
enough that it probably doesn't need a
preservative I try to stay on the safe
side. Sometimes I get really lazy and I
just mix a pinch of the vitamin C powder
with the moisturizer right before I
apply it on my face - which works for me
because my skin is quite used to acid
and so it's not that sensitive to things
like that, but if your skin isn't quite
as used to acid, proceed with massive
caution because again, irritating your
skin can cause more pigmentation.
I've talked about my love of lactic acid
before in my acid ingredients video. It's
an alpha hydroxy acid that's a little
bit larger than your standard glycolic
acid and because it's slightly larger
that means it's going to be a bit
gentler because it's harder for it to
get into the skin quite as quickly. It's
also been found to be better at
hydrating and better at treating photo
damage in some experiments. I like
glycolic acid as well but lactic acid
just happens to work better for me. I've
also been trying out mandelic acid
lately as well. Since these alpha hydroxy
acids are good for things apart from
just hyperpigmentation - so they exfoliate
and they prevent acne as well - I tend to
use them all the time, but I try to use
them more consistently and more
regularly when I'm dealing with post
inflammatory hyperpigmentation. My
favorite lactic acid products are
probably Kate Somerville's ExfoliKate
and Ultraceuticals Brightening Serum.
ExfoliKate is a really good product for
people like me who are ambitious but
kind of lazy and you sort of forget to
do your alpha hydroxy acids for a bit.
It's a mask that you use in the shower
for about two minutes and it acts like a
peel. It's particularly good because it
comes out as a thick paste so it doesn't
drip around all over the place and so it
stays on your skin in the shower. I
actually tend to leave it on for a
little bit more than two minutes because
I slowly increased my exposure to lactic
acid so I can tell that my skin can
handle it
I wouldn't recommend doing this unless
you're quite experienced with acids and
how acids act on your skin and I'd start
off really slowly following the actual
instructions before building to this
sort of exposure. The danger with going
too quickly with strong acid products is
something that a lot of people call
damaging the moisture barrier which is
when you use too much acid and you end
up giving yourself kind of like a mild
chemical burn. Your skin ends up quite
sensitive and stings and whenever you
use actives they end up just irritating
your skin quite a lot and it doesn't
help your skin recover. To wait for your
skin to recover you kind of have to
treat it really really gently and baby
it for weeks and so don't go
too hard into acids without a lot of
caution. But if you know what you're
doing
Exfolikate is really really good. It makes
my skin look smooth and glowy like I've
actually been consistently using AHAs for like weeks and weeks. It's a
little bit pricey though but a little
does go a long way with this product. You
can put a really thin film on your face
especially if you're doing it in the
shower. Try to get a sample of it if you
can, I use a little pencil eraser size
amount each time. I also really like
Ultraceutials Brightening Serum. It's
quite pricey but it was a key part of
this Ultraceuticals routine that I did
last year and my pigment faded tons and
tons during that process and so I just
don't really want to mess with this
winning formula for my skin, at least
until I run out and I have to repurchase
it. I've also tried a few other lactic
acid products that are a bit cheaper.
Tarte Knockout Tingling Treatment is one
that I've recently tried and it's been
really really good. The Ordinary have
some lactic acids. I've tried the 10% and
it's theoretically quite good but it
didn't seem to be quite as effective
when I used it, although I didn't really
use it as consistently as I wanted and I
didn't really monitor my skin that
closely, so maybe it does work better. It
could also just work better for you
because of your skin's individual needs.
I've also been trying out mandelic more
lately and it's been really good but
mandelic acid products are just a lot
harder to get. So Stratia Soft Touch AHA is probably the
most accessible one, it has 10% mandelic
acid and it comes in this really handy
pump bottle and in general if skincare
comes in a pump I'm gonna like it a lot
more because I'm quite lazy. So these
three things - sunscreen
vitamin C and lactic acid - if I use all
of these ingredients quite consistently
my PIH usually fades dramatically in the
first two weeks or so after the acne's
gone down, and it goes down enough that
it's covered with just my usual medium
coverage foundation and I actually don't
need concealer. Everyone's skin is
different so your fading process, your
skin's healing processes probably won't
be the same. It might heal faster or
slower but this is what works for me and
the evidence does
show that it does work so give it a try
maybe it'll work for you as well. Thanks
for watching this video, if you liked it
please subscribe to my channel, you can
also check out my blog, you can also
follow me on Facebook and Instagram
where I post lots of beauty tips. See you
next time for more beauty science